(ANNOUNCER 1)
Pigskins take on conference rival Armadillo High this Friday
In the first round of the playoffs
You know Coach Walker's got those boys
practicing hard to make sure they're ready for war
You think that'll get us on House of Highlights?
No. But this will
Go!
Wooooo!
Yeah, man!
You're ready for-
What the hell y'all doing?!
This ain't no circus show.
This is football.
Two hands. Always use two hands!
Why are you here?
Practice ended an hour ago
And this is MY house!
Why is this town always watching us practice
It's 6 p.m. on a Tuesday!
Don't you have families?
FOOTBALL! FOOTBALL! FOOTBALL!
Sixty-one hours until the big game against
The Armadillo High Armadillos!
It's like Chrismas Eve!
Except more religious
Hey, you guys stressed about that bio test tomorrow?
Yeah, I'm hitting up the library after practice
Who needs my help?!
Are you someone's mom or...?
Not yet, QB.
Not yet
Who needs to be adopted?!
None of us
I'm ready to open my home
And my heart
She's doing that thing from The Blind Side
Come with me!
No
You are a stranger
And adoption is a long legal process
With lots of paperwork
Well, it looks like you can teach me
just as much as I can teach you
Boys?
Bring it in
I think I've seen this lady at the gas station
We may be from different worlds
But we're all still human
What is wrong with this town?
Boys?
I...I can inspire you!